und dann es wird ihnen nicht entgangen
sein laufen seit dieser woche bilder im
fernsehen die unserer groko echte
kopfschmerzen mache man fragt sich
unwillkürlich ja ist denn heut schon
wieder 2015
die flüchtlingskrise ist zurück unser
großes trauma 2015 müssen sie noch
dieses schlimme jahr wo wir uns mal so
absurd human verhalten haben damals als
die merkel einfach grenzen aufgemacht
hat die vorher gar nicht zu wand seitdem
heißt unser mantra wir wollen nicht die
wiederholung des jahres 20 15 das jahr
2015 das sich nicht wiederholen sich die
situation von 20.15 nicht wiederholt
2015 das jahr 2015
20.15 wird sich nicht wiederholen und
darf sich nicht wiederholen
was heißt denn dass das ist das jahr
2000 nicht wiederholt jetzt muss man
dazu sagen in der geschichte unseres
planeten hat sich bis heute noch nie ein
jahr wiederholt aber wer weiß
übrigens kann sich 2015 gar nicht
wiederholen weil heute die komplette eu
inklusive deutschland nur noch an
grenzschutz denkt an nichts anderes
empathie war gestern heute gibt's
tränengas für tausende die im griechisch
türkischen niemandsland fest sitzen
natürlich will keiner noch mal völlig
unkontrollierte zuwanderung schon klar
aber wir reden ja trotzdem noch von
menschen die vom erpresser erdogan
skrupellos benutzt werden da diese
flüchtlinge die sind ja nicht von
alleine an der grenze gelangen den
ganzen tag kamen immer wieder große
gruppen von flüchtlingen an oft in
bussen kostenfrei wer sie bereitstellt
ist unklar wer könnte das gewesen sein
das aber wirklich mal der langweiligste
krimi der welt jetzt bei soko istanbul
ja natürlich
man darf sich nicht von herbert setzen
lassen wir haben uns aber auch
erpressbar gemacht der deutsche
bundestag hat diese woche gegen die
aufnahme von 5000 frauen und kindern von
den griechischen inseln gestimmt ja man
befürchtet wenn wir wieder zu viele rein
lassen dann ist bernd höcker bald
reichskanzler
es ist ja ist die befürchtung bloß keine
afd villa unnötig reizen dabei baden
doch gerade ganz andere die
flüchtlingskrise aus was soll denn die
armen menschen auf lesbos sagen früher
haben sie den hilfesuchenden brote
geschmiert und warme kleidung für den
winter gegeben jetzt wollen sie sie nur
noch loswerden
diese arschlöcher das ist alles wegen
europa und ganz besonders wegen
deutschland bitte ist das jetzt unsere
schuld dass hier in europäischen
außengrenzen wohnt dann hättet ihr land
hat nicht am mittelmeer bauen sollen
griechen wladimir putin hat im syrischen
idlib seine luft war für die russische
luftwaffe monatelang terror angriffe auf
zivilisten fliegen lassen frage ist es
für deutschland wirklich moralischen
ordnung mit demselben herrn putin
trotzdem diese neue pipeline durch die
ostsee zu bauen nummer-1-frage die
nordstream 2
ach ist in ordnung ich wollte schon mal
gefragt haben deutschland trägt wirklich
gar nichts mehr bei zur lösung der
großen konflikte auf der welt gar nichts
nichts auch unsere kanzlerin wo ist hier
eigentlich unsere kanzlerin
die hatte sich das so schön vorgestellt
die paar monate bis zur rente schön in
der uckermark vor der glotze chillen und
kartoffelsuppe aus der dose wahr machen
und dann kommt dieser blöde anruf aus
berlin angela wir haben wieder
flüchtlingskrise dies durchgedreht ihr
mann joachim ahner versucht sie zu
beruhigen großer fehler
er musste wieder die ganze nacht mit der
zahnbürste das bad putzen
na ja selber schuld
frau merkel kurz vor der grenze ein
wohnt von der flüchtlingskrise europa
hatte doch seit 2005 10 weiß gott genug
zeit endlich ein einheitliches
asylsystem auf die kette zu kriegen ist
doch peinlich ist doch peinlich
am dienstag ist die neue
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen nach griechenland geflogen um da
die europäischen werte zu verteidigen
der war gut oder nur schwach um zu
gucken wie die griechen unsere grenze
verteidigen
es ist von der leyens erste echte
bewährungsprobe als neue eu chefin und
deswegen begrüße ich an dieser stelle
claus von wagner ihren ebenfalls
adeligen referenten für
öffentlichkeitsarbeit
ja davon warten zuständig für
öffentlichkeitsarbeit bei von der leyen
wie war denn die woche bis jetzt sehr
enttäuschend aber ich sage es ihnen ganz
ehrlich diese flüchtlinge und diese
erdogan
die haben unseren terminplan komplex
erschossen er hat eigentlich nur schöne
termine auf dem zettel diese woche
mittwoch zum beispiel da wollten wir
unseren großen klimaplan für europa
präsentieren ich hatte so tolle fotos
geplant mit der chefin und mühte sich
dieses gruseliger mädchen vor der jede
angst hat haben auch genau so hat keine
sau darüber berichtet naja botschafter
andern seite aber vielleicht auch besser
so die guckt immer so böse das kind
lacht ja nie warum nach dem ii juli
macht witze hier klimaneutrale sessel
emotionen
spaßbremse und daneben noch die sache
mit den flüchtlingen worst week na ja es
gab ja dafür beeindruckende bilder von
ihrer chefin im hubschrauber fliegt da
so über das grenzgebiet und denkt auch
guck mal da unten wird also tränengas
auf die leute geschossen hh mal klar die
griechen schützen die eu-grenze keine
frage aber kein wort von user dazu dass
die da unten mal eben das asylrecht
abschaffte erwecke moment man das
asylrecht nach genfer konvention wird
nicht abgeschafft die griechen setzen
dass für einen monat aus das macht
urlaub
jeder braucht mehr urlaub brauchen sie
keinen urlaub doch doch immer öfter also
der ich muss nochmal für mich verstehen
der friedensnobelpreisträger eu setzt
das grundrecht auf asyl aus erwartet
aber von den türken dass die zusätzlich
zu den vier millionen flüchtlingen diese
schon aufgenommen haben auch noch die
eine million aus idlib aufnehmen habe
ich das sogar richtig verstanden ja
soweit richtig hat sich doch bewährt
jeder nach seinen fähigkeiten die
nebenleute auf wir geben
ab und zu geld und ratschläge genau
dasselbe auf den griechischen inseln ja
ich weiß das sind keine schönen bilder
davon lesbos aber andere haben eben auch
probleme mit ihren inseln sturmtief
sabine hat auf wangerooge und sylt
gerade ganze strände weggerissen
da helfen uns die griechen auch nicht
oder so habe ich noch gar nicht
betrachtet was würden sie sagen ist
europa dennoch eine wertegemeinschaft
selbstverständlich man die eu staaten
diskutieren ja gerade ein neues budget
was glauben sie was da für werte
verteilt werden kleiner tumor
unschlagbar meine chefin macht in
brüssel einen super job ja ihre chefin
kann froh sein dass sie die neue stelle
hat
nachdem was der untersuchungsausschuss
alles zu ihrer berater affäre rauskriegt
das ist doch jetzt lächerlich der welt
ursula von der leyen steht für maximale
transparenz bei jedem auftritt jeder
rede erfährt man alles was man über
diese frau wissen muss ursula von der
leyen ich wurde in brüssel geboren ich
komme aus niedersachsen und in der cdu
bin ich zu hause
ich habe sieben kinder und einen ehemann
ganz klar informationen konferenz
wie erwähnt nicht sogar vier
mit dass vor betont ich möchte das noch
mal betonen sieben kinder und einen
ehemann
gut umgekehrt was lustig das ist jetzt
mein humor so herberg ich muss mich
leider entschuldigen die arbeit ruft
social media für die chefin ich muss nur
das handy daten der letzten woche
löschen verstehe meine arbeit
klaus von
asylrecht aussetzen donald trump gefällt
das so der bundestag hat gestern über
eine verschärfung unseres waffenrechts
debattiert und ich sage besser ist das
besser ist das in hanau wissen sie sind
ja gerade zehn menschen von einem
rassistischen und offenbar gestörten
sportschützen ermordet worden und im
januar hat ein anderer sportschütze
sechs verwandte in baden württemberg
erschossen
tatsache ist unsere waffengesetze sind
zuletzt verschärft worden aber
offensichtlich reicht das noch nicht
findet auch gernot hassknecht alt alle
mal die fresse
jetzt rede ich über waffenrecht ja auch
das ist deutschland der deutsche
schützenbund hat mehr mitglieder als cdu
csu und spd zusammen und klar für viele
ist es einfach nur ein hobby das spaß
macht es folgt ein alter schützen witze
erzählt das ist das tolle
freizeitbeschäftigung ich komme ich
damit fit halten und es macht mir spaß
auch hier leute zu treffen
wie gesagt ich will keinen das hobby
vermissen aber natürlich könnte man
tödliche sportwaffen die eigentlich für
militärischen gebrauch entwickelt wurden
auch komplett verbieten wozu brauchen
deutsche jäger halbautomatische plätzen
die wenigsten hirscher schießen zurück
es gibt so viele tolle argumente für den
skisport in den schützenvereinen wird
jungen menschen die vielleicht ansonsten
vor dem computer blödsinn machen oder
irgendwo er war nur noch nervös werden
nur aufgeregt seien auch wieder gelernt
den körper zu beherrschen
absolut wir müssen mehr jungen böse
menschen beworfenen gutes stichwort für
eine waffenbesitzkarte braucht man in
deutschland zwar ein psychologisches
gutachten aber nur wenn man unter 25 ist
macht sinn weil über 25-jährige hagen ja
nie psychische probleme warum sind große
pistolen magazine mit bis zu 20 schuss
ohne nachladen weiter erlaubt klar man
kann menschen auch mit einem spaten
töten oder zur not mit dem thermomix
aber mit einer knarre ist es halt
einfacher sein wir doch stolz dass wir
nicht die usa sind hier schöner
übersetzungsfehler besonders aber und
das ist das wichtigste werden geschützt
seien durch waffen
nein durch gott übrigens in
großbritannien sind halbautomatische
waffen seit wir 90 komplett verboten
geht also und bei uns schreibt die
sogenannte german rifle association als
reaktion auf die morde von hanau auf
ihrer homepage da waffenbesitz
verbrechen verhindern kann
sollte der waffenerwerb für bedrohte
bürger erleichtert werden genau einen
irren mit einer waffe stopp nur ein
irrer mit einer waffe hat mahle ist eine
an der tür
bitte bitte bitte stellt die pizza
einfach da ab was die über meinen arsch
geigensolo war doch versprochen ihr
könnt ihr in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]